welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and i'm so excited to start our new
breakdown series on the undoing
i just want to get straight into it but
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the episode yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we'll be breaking down every episode
week by week
and you definitely don't want to miss
any of them now without the way thank
you for clicking this
let's get into the breakdown
okay so the theme tune of the undoing is
dream a little dream of me
which i believe is sung by nicole kidman
herself
i was given early access to the episode
and the linear notes of it haven't been
posted online yet
so let me know if i'm incorrect which
let's face it wouldn't wouldn't be the
first time
anyway the song has clearly been chosen
for a reason
and i believe that it holds a lot of
subtext to one of the central themes in
the show
now not to jump too far ahead but the
undoing is actually based heavily on the
book
you should have known this centers
around a woman's life unraveling
as she discovers her husband jonathan
isn't really who she thinks he is
jonathan becomes the prime suspect in a
murder investigation
and we will likely follow her as she
gets to the bottom of this
i'm not going to go any further beyond
what happens than that as i don't want
to ruin the entirety of the show
but as it's in the trailer i think it's
okay to discuss how that motif is set up
here
now dream a little dream of me is of
course referring to grace
played by kidman and how she initially
views her life with her husband
and their son henry everything seems
perfect
and on the surface her life is almost
like a dream
the child that appears in the
introduction seems to be a younger
version of grace
and she even wears what appears to be a
wedding dress at one point in the intro
it symbolizes that in her marriage she
is pretty much a child
and not fully aware of the situation at
hand throughout this episode
there is this feeling that she's almost
above others and nowhere is this
demonstrated more than in the therapy
session
that we see her giving early on she
talks things through with a client known
as rebecca hawkness
and accuses her of being unable to see
men for what they really are
because of this rebecca has gone from
marriage to marriage to marriage
looking for something that she believes
is there when it's revealed
not to be over time rebecca says that
her husband is bipolar
meaning that he has almost two sides and
that she's unable to truly work out
what's going on with him
now this conversation is ironic as grace
herself cannot truly see her husband for
what he is
and she lives almost in this bubble of
idealism only accepting the version of
reality that she wants to
jonathan pretends to be allergic to dogs
to his son
and grace plays along with this almost
accepting this version of events
even though the truth is much darker she
even rings about hotels
trying to locate him at the end of the
episode and gets through to someone with
his name who is a completely different
person
this hammers home the duality to the
character and poetically brings to life
that there are two versions of jonathan
that exist now i know jonathan
isn't literally two people yet and this
person on the phone
isn't him but the symbolism of his
dichotomy
i feel is definitely there with this it
shows just how oblivious grace really is
to the true nature of their marriage
and i love the way that this aesthetic
carries on throughout the entry
at one point grace and jonathan even
talk about how their son henry
is unprepared for the real world because
they've kept him trapped in a bubble
and it becomes clear that grace is in
one too unable to truly comprehend the
way that the world is
her entire life is pretty much built
around repetition and order
and nowhere is this exemplified more
than when we see her going about her
routine
the exact same music plays and even the
scene itself
is shot almost beat for beat grace and
her friends are all about image
and we very much get the idea that
everything is surface level
all simply pageantry this aesthetic is
cemented in an auction
which is being held for the school in
order to raise funds for the fantastic
teachers
who are so good that they aren't even
invited to the event
jonathan complains about this fundraiser
when he says he already pays for the
school
however it's actually grace's father
who's bankrolling their son's education
and yeah no one has a real grasp of
what's truly going on
there's also a comment on how the school
does certain things purely for diversity
and again there's this subtext here that
it's likely just a marketing tactic
in order to help out the school's image
any actual honesty is looked at with
disgust
and we see this through the entry namely
in how people treat eleanor
a woman who we learn is brutally
murdered at one point in the episode she
breastfeeds her child
and though this is pretty commonplace
the rest of the group looked down on it
showing that they would rather have
certain things hidden away from public
view
namely what they class as personal
everyone is trying to just seem like
they're good people
when in reality they probably aren't now
i absolutely
love this duality that exists in the
characters i do think it's very subtle
that the show pretty much laces
every single person with a flip side to
their personality
the only one who is honest and willing
to bear all is eleanor
who am strips down at one point and uh
just respect personal boundaries here
now we learned that elena's son
was accepted onto a scholarship at
reardon school
the prestigious academy to which grace
is a committee member of
helena is very much only involved with
them because of her son's abilities
and thus she's sort of viewed as an
outcast eleanor clearly has some mental
issues as well
and when she's at the meeting she makes
several strange glances towards grace
sits outside the school just staring
into it and also
again has no damn personal boundaries
now something is clearly off with her
and the brief interactions we do get
make it seem like she's hiding something
which we likely won't find out about
probably because she's dead now as
mentioned earlier grace and jonathan
attend an auction
and here elena just seems to be staring
at grace throughout
however it's also possible that she is
looking at jonathan
i'm kind of joining the dots here and
being captain obvious
but jonathan is of course tied to her
murder in some way
as we know that he does become a suspect
in the case
this is all just shown in the trailer
and though we don't know who was behind
the attack
i can tell you it's not hugh it's me
eh you're having that now pretty much
right after alanet arrives
jonathan tries to make grace leave even
though they just got there
when grace comes back from the elevator
jonathan starts asking questions
immediately
and it all seems to be pointing one way
when elena goes
he suddenly doesn't really want to leave
the party anymore and instead stays with
grace
until he decides to leave himself under
the guise that he has a patient to
attend to
jonathan arrives later that night and as
we see from elena's partner
she doesn't return home elena is later
found dead the next day
and we know it's not the boyfriend but
we can't really account for jonathan's
whereabouts
beyond the hospital now not long after
eleanor's body is discovered
jonathan disappears leaving his phone at
home and he would likely only do this
if he was aware that she was dead before
it made the news
thus something is clearly going on here
and though i don't want to spoil the
series just yet
things all seem to be pointing towards
him the episode ends with grace
discovering that he's in fact vanished
leaving behind the only way to contact
him things are strange
i'm guessing that next time the
attention will fall on her
as the police try to get to the bottom
of elena's death
in the book the character was actually
called malaga and i think that this name
change has been done on purpose
to perhaps show that the series could go
a different way
maybe maybe it was the sun there was a
strange reason why you missed the bus
that's a terrible theory isn't it
however what a great episode
this was and i have to say i really
enjoyed it and it's multiple layers
i think there's a lot of things that
they could do here and with the season
just being six episodes long
i'm expecting quite a condensed
storyline that doesn't really mess about
with filler episodes
this was a great premise and hopefully
you enjoyed the breakdown too
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the first entry
as well as what your theories are if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the finale of lovecraft
country which is going to be linked at
the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winners are going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chapters
on the discord server
linked in the description or heavy
spoilers on twitter thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you